see those dazzling bowling arcs those
are the sun's magnetic fields traced in
glowing arches of gas that activity is
invisible to you and me but the Solar
Dynamics Observatory a satellite
hovering 22,000 miles above the earth
can see it by focusing in on extreme
ultraviolet wavelengths of light those
magnetically active areas are the
sources of energetic solar storms ones
that erupt in flashes of light and
sometimes explosive ejections of matter
the satellite isn't up there just to
make pretty pictures it's there to help
or neuss about those potentially
dangerous explosions occasionally those
solar belches make it all the way to our
planet interfering with GPS satellites
and other spacecraft in orbit including
the one capturing these magnificent
images one day it may just record the
solar storm that leads to the
observatories demise